National Criminal Courts as the current
violence in Darfur Falls within its
existing mandate investigating alleged
war crimes and crimes against humanity
in the region prosecutors are said to be
closely tracking reports of
extrajudicial killings sexual violence
the burning of homes and markets looting
and the displacement of civilians in
West and North Darfur we have already
started investigating as I said and Mr
President and Excellence says I do want
to be clear
and send a clear message to every
belligerent every Commander every foot
soldier who has a gun
or believes that they have power to do
what they want
that targeting civilians
individuals
targeting their homes targeting their
businesses
intentionally
particularly targeting children and
women
are crimes prohibited
by the Rome statute comb specifically
mentioned reports from the U.N human
rights office that the rapid support
forces and their Allied militia had
killed at least 87 ethnic macellites who
were subsequently buried in a mass grave
Observer sets part of a coordinated
campaign of ethnic cleansing and there
is ample evidence of the fighting
engineer not being a battle between the
Army and the representative forces and
militias supporting the Episcopal forces
but rather a campaign of ethnic
cleansing at a massive scale with the
rapid support forces Fighters and
militias aligned with them going door to
door asking people about their ethnicity
executing entire families based on their
identification as massari the
predominant uh indigenous tribe in
invest their food however the ICC said
the Sudanese government was no longer
cooperating with its investigation nor
does the ICC have any investigators on
the ground in Sudan nonetheless the
prosecutor warned National Regional and
international actors that there would be
no impunity for crimes currently being
committed in
darfurtancy Al Jazeera the United
Nations